hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Gotham episode 13 video it
was a good story that proved that the
criminals aren't the only bad people in
the city Gotham in general is full of
really crappy people and this just put
the focus more on people who would
normally think are legit so just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet starting with top five
moments number five fish Mooney is
plopped on the table like fresh fish
getting ready to get carved up I really
love the spirit of this scene although
there were some moments that got a
little hammy I've always felt like Jada
Pinkett is channeling a little bit of
Eartha Kitt and her performances which i
think is totally appropriate for this
setting
well when you see someone go into a
torture chamber like that makeshift
torture chamber you're expecting to see
something from a Saw movie like some
crazy torture porn it's too bad the show
isn't on basic cable because some of
those core to it is shots even zas
coming to clean up later would have been
really effective that's one of the
things that shows like Game of Thrones
has in its favor being on HBO it can
show you someone getting their head
squished like a grape
so you get a lot of extra people talking
about the show just because something so
crazy happened that you would never
expect on screen generally you can't
really do that with network shows but
Gotham Gotham gets pretty close I was
kind of hoping when Bob pulled out the
power tools that he'd draw a little
blood
I feel like Jada pinkett-smith she's a
great actress so she'd be willing to
take it to that place so it was a little
bit of a bummer that they chose to play
it safe butch to the rescue don't you
just wonder what's going on between the
two of them
I feel like fish Mooney has really close
relationships with a lot of different
people and not just men she had that
weird connection with Liza like she was
trying to be her mother but she was more
like a big sister or even some sort of
passive lover then you have her
relationship with butch which seems
really close really genuine friendship I
felt kind of bad after what happened to
him but I don't think he's dead after
that that book looks like he really
enjoys her flavor of fish you can make
as many jokes about that as you want
Bullock likes fresh fish that was
actually that Bullock scene at the end
that was really probably the most
touching fish Mooney moment she seemed
much more like a person and less like a
comic book villain I really do want to
learn more about what's going on between
her and Bullock though number four the
Penguins acid trip victory montage of
all the montages in the episode there
were several this was the craziest I
almost put it on my thumbs down list but
it's one of those things that's so bad
that it's good it's almost like he's
having a two-minute orgasm in that
speech that he gives that is so funny
like he just starts to go crazy and fish
mooney walks in if you haven't read the
comics the penguin actually does own his
own club it's called the iceberg lounge
and later it was renamed to the iceberg
casino he turned it into a casino
there's a High Roller area in the back
where super criminals go to meet there's
a restaurant up top as a character the
penguin loves the trappings of high
society so owning an upscale club is
totally natural for the character
although the penguin on this show is a
long way out from that did anyone else
spin out their drink whenever he was
standing next to that big fish plaque
that was just was so ridiculous but you
loved it so much I totally don't mind
when Gotham gets a little cheesy as long
as it leans into the curve having his
mother around helps a lot too she is
just so wild whenever she met Gordon I
felt like she was gonna try and eat him
alive I'm more scared of her than I am
of any of the other villains on the show
number three Victor Zsasz cleans up the
mess it wouldn't be a party without mr.
no eyebrows that's actually a good way
to creep people out just shave your
eyebrows off you'll be ten times scarier
not quite as scary as the Penguins
mother but still pretty scary of all the
montages in the episode his felt like
the most fun just because he felt like a
steamroller like he was unstoppable
somebody should tell him not to play
with his food I kind of wished that he
would have finished off butch but I
understand why they're keeping him on
the show he's a fairly valuable
character especially when fish Mooney is
around so they're gonna want to bring
him back in the back half of the season
I think that's why they gave him that
antihero escape moment earlier in the
episode whenever he busted out of the
back of the truck Batman style and
escaped it's a fairly common shot but
any time you see a character look one
way and then there's nothing and then
look back and also then someone's there
people just think of that as Batman now
like that's pulling a Batman on someone
anytime they give a character that kind
of shot like that they give him that
type of moment you know they're getting
ready to do something badass so I'm
actually I'm waiting for the Riddler to
get a shot like that that's what I want
to see number two the Riddler and Miss
Kringle
what gives away really awesome gifts and
is probably going to go crazy before the
end of this season answer the best
character on this show that might be a
bit of a stretch the Riddler might not
be the best character on the show but
he's definitely one of my favorite any
character that can bounce back and forth
really easily between crazy and funny is
amazing in my book I think them adding
this young love died
- it makes it that much funnier - who's
that like the awkward component of him
really liking Miss Kringle and all these
other douchebag cops just stomping all
over him
that's why I was kind of bummed at the
end of the episode when Gordon took
flash down I was kind of hoping that the
Riddler was gonna do something crazy or
that that card that he left was gonna
turn out to be something a little more
sinister like he was gonna try and turn
the tables on them we're not we're not
to that territory yet and he actually it
seemed pretty hopeful the way that he
ended with Miss Kringle looking at her
character like she hasn't had that many
lines I felt like her reaction was
probably the best it could have possibly
been just don't just don't speak don't
make it worse that moment almost felt
uncomfortably autobiographical who has
not been in a situation like that and my
number 1 moment Gordon and Bullock
versus the commissioner
make no mistake even though vlas was the
criminal they arrested at the end of
this episode the Commissioner was the
real villain the captain explained that
all the the steamrolling that happened
to everyone in the episode was because
the Commissioner was putting his weight
behind it so the false report about the
suicide all Commissioner the stash
houses in the dirty cops Commissioner I
don't think he's gonna end up being the
biggest villain of the season I don't
think it's gonna be that simple so now
I'm actually wondering who he's working
with I wouldn't be surprised if it ends
up being someone on the Wayne board we
haven't met yet someone behind the venom
precursor when you look at the villains
of the season you have the street
criminals you have like fish Mooney you
have the mob then you have the
white-collar criminals that the people
in the Wayne foundation the commissioner
people that work inside the government
it makes you wonder if there are any
heroes in positions of power so don't be
surprised if in some big twist Falcone
ends up being one of the protagonists
even though technically he's one of the
biggest villains that's one of the
charms of Gotham is that everyone is bad
so when you try to differentiate between
protagonists and antagonists you really
end up picking from the same bucket
here's my big question for you guys who
do you think is gonna be the bigger
villain at the end of the season is
gonna be the commissioner or is it gonna
be Falcone I'm kind of hoping they don't
roll out too many new characters usually
you want to meet who all the important
people are by the first half of this
season or even in the first couple of
episodes I think the writers are still
finding the voices of all the characters
so it is getting better with each
episode so I'm really optimistic for
like the last arc of the season usually
what you get is you get like two mini
arcs you get like a block of three or
four episodes that
tell like a minor story next week's
episode is actually gonna be a
two-parter they will be doing a
scarecrow ish type story like a Jonathan
crane fear toxin prequel story here are
some of the bigger Easter eggs that I
saw in the episode but but if you sunny
that I don't mention just feel free to
write them in in the comments so I
already mentioned the penguins club the
iceberg lounge or the iceberg casino
however you want to think about it we
have the Riddler's notes he's already
left clues now he's starting to leave
his signature notes when Alfred and
Bruce are walking around he tells him
he's gonna get ripped to shreds by the
females but just that feels like a
Catwoman fight waiting to happen
the drugs that Gordon finds aren't
specified by name but they remind me of
the venom derivative in terms of really
notable drugs shows typically find
something and stick with it like on
arrow for instance they're sticking with
vertigo even though they did it in
season two I didn't see any big Easter
eggs during the poison ivy scene but you
guys can let me know if you spotted any
right at the end Bruce actually he talks
about going to Switzerland I'm trying to
remember I think that he actually
battled racial goal in Switzerland like
it was part of a racial story arc in the
Batman comics but somebody can feel free
to correct me on that so as much fun as
the episode was there were a couple of
thumbs down I had a couple things I felt
just didn't work the Bruce Wayne
Catwoman scene at the end where she
rejects him obviously very clearly likes
him so much that he's pushing him away I
felt like that was the ball forced Plus
Bruce crying later anything with Bruce
crying just get rid of that I feel like
it's just interminable so a couple
awesome montages in the episode but the
first one where Gordon started to
question the police had this really
weird music playing behind it like it
was meant to be funny but it just ended
up sounding a little weird and then the
penguin kissing fish Mooney's feet that
was another so bad that it's good moment
but I put it on the thumbs down listed
because it was so over the top like it
was crazy you guys can let me know that
I mean do you like it when the show does
really crazy things where it's just like
okay they are very clearly not taking
themselves super seriously sometimes it
can be fun sometimes it doesn't work so
big stuff next week is gonna be the
beginning of a two-part episode so be
sure to subscribe to get that
new episode of the flash tomorrow and
then a new episode of arrow there have
been some liberal spoilers for episode
13 of arrow I'm not gonna mention him
here but it has to do with what's going
on with Oliver and laurels Black Canary
so
if you want to read about that you can
just go to IMDB I'm freaking excited
about it but it's just too spoilery to
mention so while you guys wait for the
flash tomorrow you can click here to
learn all about Gorilla Grodd in the
comics the producer said that he is
coming back in season one they didn't
say which episode and you can click here
for last week's episode of Gotham thank
you so much for watching
so guerrilla size high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow